okay so She-Hulk episode 3 has finally
found its footing with the law
procedural introduced the Asgardian
Village People and uh did did this yeah
um my body is very confused but some of
the biggest questions still looming over
everything are who or what is the
antagonist of this series is that the
end of Blonsky as we know it and
seriously where is Hulk he was supposed
to check in this episode but we got
nothing anyway throughout this video
we're going to be talking about our
thoughts and theories on what is
happening so far if you enjoy this video
then Hulk smash that thumbs up button
and also don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns and theories like this every
day with that out of the way thank you
for clicking this now let's get into the
video now a big thing that happens at
the end of episode 3 is Jen's run in
with the Wrecking Crew each sporting
their neon colored Rave gear these
characters actually pull straight from
the comics each wielding mystical
weapons however I do believe that their
origin story will differ a bit here in
the comics they all obtain their powers
when they latched on to an enchanted
crowbar just as a bolt of lightning had
Struck it the four members of wrecker
bulldozer Thunderball and pile driver
then obtained their mystical Powers
however in this series it's said that
they robbed in Asgardian construction
worker so um I guess less lightning
bolts and more home loan wet Bandits
here either way it doesn't seem like
this will be the last we see of them
according to the trailers it appears
that their mission here was to extract
she-hulk's blood and it's teased that
they are working for someone else at
this point there hasn't been any mention
of any other big baddies but if we look
at Whom The Wrecking Crew has kind of
had ties within the comics along with
the upcoming MCU projects one person
they could be working for is Parker
Robbins aka the hood the hood being
played by Anthony Ramos is supposed to
be the villain of the upcoming ironheart
Series so this could be I guess a
somewhat soft introduction action to the
character in the comics at a young age
he witnessed Daredevil fighting Electro
and ever since was kind of enticed by
this super villain lifestyle one night
when trying to pull a heist in a
warehouse he was attacked by a demon in
a cloak Parker then shot and killed it
stripping it of its Red Cloak and Boots
which then gave him the ability to turn
invisible along with Walking on Air he
later became the Kingpin of crime in New
York recruiting other villains into his
gang of which were The Wrecking Crew
this explains obviously the connection
with the Wrecking Crew here and who they
could potentially be working for but
with She-Hulk taking place in California
either Jen is going to the big apple or
Daredevil is making one of the most
chaotic road trips across the United
States anyway this would nicely set up
ironheart as one of the upcoming MCU
series and the hood who is obviously
playing the main antagonist however I
think the more plausible person to have
hired The Wrecking Crew is Titania sure
she kind of went out like a jump in the
first episode but her presence has been
subtly seen throughout every episode in
different news stories also the real
life actress playing Titania Jamila
Jamel has been seen defacing She-Hulk
posters as Titania in new viral video
marketing so it looks like she'll be
making much more of an appearance later
down the road in She-Hulk with Titania
being this sort of influencer superhero
and She-Hulk is now taking all of the
headlines and fame it seems on brand for
her character to be behind all of this
and actually ties in with the comics
because she-hulk's first major arc saw
her scoring off against Titania as her
main antagonist ending in a brawl in the
Supreme Court which is kind of teased
with the courtroom fight in episode 1.
and ever since that first encounter
Titania has held that resentment for
She-Hulk cementing her as her arch
nemesis if anything Titania is doing
this to boost her image social media
numbers hell maybe even sell a couple
only fan subscriptions who am I to judge
basically it's what any celebrity would
do to have their comeback moment Rocky
yes Kim Kardashian Kim well in the video
she gets she gets come on her back I
think now what exactly is The Wrecking
Crew after seems fairly obvious that
being Jen's DNA or blood this was
foreshadowed in episode 1 when Hulk
destroys Jen's blood after testing it
saying that it's far too dangerous for
her DNA to get out into the world it's
way too dangerous to get out in the
world even if there's only a millionth
percent chance that it makes another one
of us Jen's DNA in theory could make
another Hulk a green Hulk Red Hulk who
gives or even enhance someone else's
powers like what we saw in the
Incredible Hulk with the Abomination if
Titania is in fact Behind These Wrecking
Crew Shenanigans she's trying to get the
hot new thing on the market essentially
Jen's powers in doing so Titania will
likely have her powers enhanced to the
extremes but like the Abomination it'll
morph her into something a little less
let's say Instagram worthy which will
drive her rage towards She-Hulk further
this could also be taking liberties with
Titania's Origins from the comics where
she met with Dr Doom during Secret Wars
he later experimented on her with alien
technology that imbued her with the
powers of superhuman strength now in
this origin Titania grows in size well
the She-Hulk show she currently looks
like your average everyday influencer so
the She-Hulk a DNA will allow this
further transformation being able to be
a worthy match against the larger
She-Hulk now let's talk about the X-Men
I know you've all been waiting for it
since we first found out about the
mutants in the MCU you know when
Professor X shows up as an Illuminati
member in the Multiverse of Madness or
wait no no actually it's when Ms Marvel
reveals mutants are alive and well yeah
yeah that's the one okay disregard all
of that mutants are in the MCU and the
X-Men are coming a lot sooner than you
may have expected specifically Wolverine
yes the big hairy man with claws was
teased in episode 2 in the news article
on Jen's computer titled man fights with
metal claws in bar fight who was he
fighting probably Ezra Miller
[Applause]
DC slander got him but with d23 quickly
approaching Kevin feige May finally be
revealing what all of these mutant
breadcrumbs are leading to in phase six
of the MCU now if these X-Men teases are
in fact evidence that they are coming to
the MCU sooner rather than later A crazy
out there Theory going back to who
actually hired The Wrecking Crew ties
directly into the heart of the X-Men
lore and that would be Mr Sinister
that guy now if you aren't aware Mr
Sinister also known as Dr Nathan Essex
was this Charles darwin-esque Victorian
scientist who believed that evolutionary
human Perfection was possible and that
Humanity as a whole was going through
increasing amounts of mutation
furthering his research he discovered
that some humans have mutant genetics
for example Ms Marvel that makes them
superhuman in some form or another he
then essentially discovered the first
mutant in sabana or rather apocalypse
whom agreed with his research making
Essex into a mutant calling himself Mr
Sinister years go on and Essex becomes
obsessed with cloning manipulation of
DNA essentially Gathering research to
create the perfect human race this is
where the X-Men come into play with
Essex slowly trying to gather bits and
pieces of their DNA to replicate each of
their superpowers for his own
Sinister purposes
man now the reason he could be pulling
all of the strings thus teasing the
X-Men further is most recently in the
comics The Wrecking Crew was hired by
him to retrieve the adamantium encased
body of Wolverine from some wreckage
essentially a fetch Quest now this could
be adapted from that storyline towards
she-hulk's DNA they were tasked with
retrieving a sample so Mr Sinister can
experiment and replicate this for his
own research setting him up as the main
antagonist for the X-Men movies Mr
Sinister AKA Nathan Essex was actually
set up in 2016's X-Men apocalypse when
the post-credits scene features several
men in suits adding weapon X's blood to
a briefcase that has Essex Corp listed
on it it would be interesting to see
this X-Men villain realized in live
action and I think it would be a solid
big bad for the first few X-Men movies
to get things moving now there was one
key component missing from this third
episode of She-Hulk and that was Hee
Hawk I mean Hulk a banner yes Bruce
Banner yeah we last saw him in episode 2
aboard the sicarian curio craft that was
seen and also mentioned in episode 1. so
it's very much hinting at the fact that
Banner is going to return to sakhar for
some apparent reason could it be a
five-year Gladiator reunion doubtful
instead I believe this is going to be
him going back to discover that Hulk has
a son yes the big green guy is finally
going to have a little green guy this is
taken from the world war Hulk Story
comic line where it's revealed that Hulk
had a son named scar we did a more
extensive video on this a couple weeks
ago so click it click up there do it you
Marvel Chumps but a brief overview of it
all reveals Hulk being stranded on
sakhar becomes the almighty Gladiator
that we see in Ragnarok and leads a
rebellion that essentially puts him in
the role of leader of the planet in the
process of doing this he has a wife they
have a child but unfortunately his wife
dies in an explosion that sets forth the
events of world war Hulk with him
returning to Earth with his son Scar and
and getting revenge for his wife
battling all of the Marvel Heroes to the
death and it being revealed that Hulk
has a son isn't too surprising at all
because Banner wanting a child has been
hinted a handful of times throughout the
previous films the most obvious example
is when banner and Natasha are having
the conversation together on Clint's
Farm in Age of Ultron Banner says I
can't ever I can't have this
kids
do the math I physically can't but
another more subtle or I guess less
subtle I guess it depends how good you
are at picking up Clues is when Natasha
meets Banner for the first time in The
Avengers when they are talking Banner
looks at a makeshift bassinet and says
well I don't every time get what I want
both times heavily hint that one of
Banner's dreams in life is to have a
child however it is physically
impossible because of his Gammy genitals
so fulfilling this long forgotten dream
would drastically change Hawk's
mentality potentially his character in
general and would fully put forth the
events to set up a World War Hulk
storyline because Banner will protect
his child at all cost so even if he
meets up with his old Avengers Pals for
a happy hour his son is the number one
priority now with Blonsky being released
this early in the season was a bit
surprising for myself I honestly thought
they might draw this thing out cover the
whole season some more twists and turns
with the trial eventually revealing that
Blonsky making a deal with Valentina
Allegra de Fontaine much like John
Walker and Elena did at the end of
Falcon in the Winter Soldier and black
widow respectively it's not explicitly
been revealed that she is recruiting for
the Thunderbolts but come on she's an
associate of an organization interest
tested in recruiting powerful
individuals it's it's not Starbucks
folks and with William hurt's AKA
General Ross's unfortunate passing I
think she will be taking on the role of
leader or organizer shifting from the
comic Source material just a bit we know
a Thunderbolts movie is on the horizon
for a 2024 release and the Abomination
has been a reoccurring member of this
group via the comics so I'm guessing
that the end of this series a
post-credits stinger will reveal Val
approaching Blonsky on his plot of land
recruiting him for the group now sure
Blonsky seems rehabilitated he has his
seven different slam pieces he even is
forced to wear a similar inhibitor to
what Banner was wearing at the beginning
of this season to prevent him from ever
turning into the Abomination again but
one tiny thing will shift his decision
when Val tries to recruit him she will
allude to the fact that he can finally
get his chance to be a hero like bloody
Captain America which is almost a word
for word what he thought he would become
when taking the super soldier serum I
thought I was
I was going to be
Captain bloody America something your
cousin is held up as some kind of hero
and I'm locked up in here
[Music]
where's the Justice in that gen even
though his life seems to be sunshine and
mid-summer wives there's still a
Redemption deep down that he's looking
for thou will use her tools and
persuasion to reel Blonsky in for the
Thunderbolts joining the other members
of John Walker Elana and Zemo for this
Suicide Squad esque group
that's it what we some kind of Suicide
Squad we're running a competition right
now giving away three copies of top gun
Maverick on the 15th of September and
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is like this video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts and theories we
picked the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now so if that's
you message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers if you want something else to
watch be sure to check out our full
breakdown of She-Hulk episode 3 which
will be linked on screen right now we go
over all of the Easter eggs in it
callbacks to the comics and it's
definitely worth checking out if you
have any sort of questions of what's
going on with that out of the way thanks
for sticking through this video I'm
Jared I'm new please be nice and I'll
see you in the next one take care and
peace